à présent les slits carretero
journaliste pour le site info migrants
qui appartient au même groupe que france
24 et rfi pour soi riesling ça vous avez
passé plusieurs jours en roumanie que
vous êtes rentré dimanche dernier
précisément vous étiez à la frontière
avec l'ukraine à six raids dans la nuque
de siret vous avez été marqués vous
m'avez dit par un mouvement de
solidarité très fort oui alors on en a
un peu parlé le tour des tables mais
c'est vrai que quand je suis arrivé à la
frontière j'ai été assez impressionné
par ce mouvement de personnes et
beaucoup de citoyens en fait volontaire
qui sont venus spontanément apporté leur
aide donc soit distribué de la
nourriture faire la traduction
même accueillir des personnes chez eux
ce qui m'a le plus impressionné c'est de
voir les autorités en fait qui ont eux
aussi participer à l'effort elle aussi
participer à l'effort pardon j'ai
notamment vu des pompiers ou des
policiers tirer eux mêmes les valises
des déplacés ukrainiens et les orienter
vers des cars vers des centres
d'hébergement d'urgence ou vers des
voitures regard des citoyens et c'est
quelque chose que l'on ne voit pas
souvent nous en tant que journaliste
alors justement vous êtes juriste
spécialiste de ces questions de
migration vous suivez pour info migrants
ces dossiers là depuis des années et
alors on est quoi ce qu'on a dit
précédemment dans l'émission vous avez
le sentiment qu'il ya une différence de
traitement selon les populations ce
qu'on pourrait appeler ça un deux poids
deux mesures oui alors c'est vrai que
pour nous journalistes d'infos migrants
qui comme vous le dites travaillant sur
le sujet depuis longtemps on n'a jamais
vu un tel accueil il ya toujours eu des
ong des citoyens qui se portaient
volontaires mais alors que les autorités
se demandent si accueillante c'est très
rare notamment dans ces pays là
je rappelle que la hongrie qui fait
partie donc des trois des trois pays
européens en tout cas qui accueille le
plus de personnes a été condamné à
plusieurs reprises par la courbe de
cours européennes pardon de
des droits de l'homme pour mauvais
traitements envers les demandeurs
d'asile et également pour avoir enfermé
des demandeurs d'asile dans des centres
dans des centres fermés le dernier
jugement date de novembre 2021 donc
c'est encore très récent la pologne
aussi actuellement encore à la frontière
avec la biélorussie il ya des centaines
et des milliers de personnes qui sont
refoulés principalement des personnes
qui viennent du moyen-orient et qui sont
renvoyés de manière très violent de côté
biélorusse ils ne peuvent même pas de
déposer l'asile nous on a eu des
témoignages de gens qui nous racontent
qu'ils ont été frappés qu'ils ont reçues
qui ont reçu des coups et lorsqu'il
arriva à pénétrer enfin sur le sol
polonais après avoir passé des heures
des jours dans la frontiste dans la
forêt environnante à se cacher et bien
là ils sont encore une fois parqués dans
des centres dans des centres fermés ils
ne peuvent pas en sortir et ça peut
durer plusieurs mois alors la roumanie
c'est un peu moins catastrophique si je
peux dire ça comme ça mais moi j'ai
encore eu un témoignage la semaine fin
l'année dernière par nom d'un sénégalais
qui me racontait qu'il avait essayé de
passer la frontière depuis la serbie et
qu'ils avaient été violentés par les
gardes-frontière roumain qui lui avait
volé ses affaires est inclus avec il
avait aussi renvoyé manu militari côté
serbe sens là aussi avoir pu déposer
l'asile donc en effet selon là là où on
arrive c'est le sait c'est plus
compliqué nous l'avons pas de la
roumanie la pologne la biélorussie mes
parents est ce qu'en france aussi on
observe ces différences de traitement
parce qu'il ya des afflux de réfugiés et
craignant on va en parler en france oui
il ya des afflux d'autres personnes
aussi en france on parle beaucoup du
crâne en ce moment mais
la france alors là j'ai vu que pour
préparer et coordonner l'arrivée des
ukrainiens le gouvernement a mis en
place une cellule de crise
interministérielle
ils ont ouvert une plate forme où chaque
citoyen français peut s'inscrire pour
héberger un ukrainien chez lui ils ont
ouvert des places d'hébergement
supplémentaires là encore c'est des
choses qu'on ne voit pas on n'a pas vu
ça pendant la guerre en syrie on n'a pas
vu ça encore il ya très peu de temps en
afghanistan avec l'afghanistan cet été
où il ya eu quand même la reprise du
pouvoir par les talibans en afghanistan
il ya eu un flot un port important de
migrants ou de réfugiés selon
l'appellation qu'on veut bien qu'on veut
bien leur donner alors certes à cette
époque là la france a accueilli 3000
afghans mais il ya encore des gens qui
sont arrivés après en fait et qui sont
actuellement dans les rues de paris et
qui n'ont aucune aide on peut aussi
parler de calais où là aussi il ya des
afghans il ya des sous d'années il ya
des syriens il ya des gens qui peuvent
prétendre au statut de réfugié et akalé
là aussi il ya une grosse différence on
a vu la maire de calais natacha bouchart
qui accueille en grande pompe les
réfugiés ukrainien qui kills qui ouvre
des hébergements qui a même réservé
d'aider des restaurants pour eux alors
qu'à côté il ya des personnes qui sont
qui sont dans la rue dans les campements
informels je rappelle quand même que
natacha bouchart la maire de calais a
interdit les distributions de nourriture
aux exilés dans la ville par les ong non
mandatés par l'état avec l'aide de la
préfecture c'est quand même une mère qui
a posé des rochers amis des arts sauts
de vélo qui a déboisé des terrains où
étaient
restés les personnes et tout ça pour
éviter des campements se reforme alors à
calais la semaine dernière les
associations me disais que d'énoncer
clairement une logique raciste et elle
réfléchissait à a porté plainte contre
la mairie mais aussi contre l'état pour
pour discrimination